For me, the most important thing is the story that I'm telling.
whether it's a scary set piece, or a dramatic moment,
It all comes down to the character
and if you care about them
Aquaman is very powerful,
But what drives him comes from a very human place.
The story resonated with me instantly.
He's not accepted here, not really accepted here..
Definitely can identify with that.
I fell in love with the project, and fell in love with Mera.
She's no damsel in distress.
She's this strong, badass, empowered superhero.
With Aquaman, the trick and also part of the fun
is designing this whole world that we've never seen before.
You're pretty much just limited by your own imagination.
There's just a whole lot of magic in this project.
Once they put all these things together behind James's vision,
Blows my mind still.
The appeal of it was to step into something else.
You really are invigorated because of it.
You get to experience all these amazing worlds.
We haven't been under the ocean yet.  This is our outer space.
I keep going back to that inherent fascination we have with the ocean.
...and if it turned on you.
Just the sheer vastness and the mystery of it
There's still a lot we don't know.
I've always known that I wanted to do an action movie.
I get to be a big kid on the playground, and cause trouble.
...blow things up.
Your body is constantly working.
Judo, Jiujitsu, fight choreography.
After 4.5 months of stunt training,
6 days a week...
you feel pretty superhuman.
I get to present Aquaman to the world in this really
baddass and cool way.
We have never seen this on screen.
That's the truth.
You get to fall in love with the idea of what it's like to have these powers...and be a kid.
And that's fun for the family.  It's fun for everyone.
We want to create something interesting.
We don't want the standard.
James Wong can't do the standard.
Any great superhero story should make you feel
that you've learned something from these characters.
And you yourself have the ability to do good.
And you don't need a cape to be able to do that.
Hey everybody, it's Charlie.  We've got a whole bunch of new Aquaman footage to break down.
Mostly a behind-the-scenes trailer, but you actually get
a couple of really cool comic book moments.
You get a much better look at some of the characters.  There's a new round of that IMAX ticket
giveaway.  All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave an Aquaman-related comment on the video.
So the big thing they start out with is actually the forging of
Atlan's trident.  And I don't know if they're gonna call it the
Trident of Poseidon, but you probably saw that the quindent that he used
in Justice League and Batman v Superman, everything up to this point,
is his mother's.  So that's what he's training with on the beach
here with Vulko.
This is a moment right out of the comic book.  If you haven't read it, this is the New 52 run.
I would recommend checking that out.  It's actually pretty solid
It's Jeff Johns through and through
There was an arc they were going to do called "Unite the 7 Seas", but they ended up having to cancel.
Because everything got rebooted during rebirth.
So I assume whatever the plot of that was going to be, they're going to deal
with during the movie.  So it seem like when she goes back to Atlantis
to resume her duties as Queen, she leaves some things behind
for Arthur when he gets older, and her quindent
is just one of those.  There's a whole bunch of new Mera footage.
But the cool thing about Mera, is that
in some extra material that they release for the film,
you get a look at childhood scribblings
of Aquaman's in journals that he was writing about himself.
He was learning about normal world history, as well as Atlantean
history.  And he started to wonder about what's going on with Mera.
So he thinks about King Nereus, he has a daughter that's about
my age living down there.  It'd be so much cooler to live down there.
So it's a way for them to show you how he's not really welcome on
land, and he doesn't really know what's going on in
Atlantis, but he assumes that it's better at that point.
But as an adult we know that he feel like he's shunned by them,
or at least he doesn't feel welcome there.  So that's why during Justice League
it seems like he's trying to avoid Atlantis as much as possible.
This is another shot of Dolph Lundgren, King Nerues
inside his Vul armor.  You notice there's a couple
different types of armor that you see.  These are Atlantean
soldiers.  It's Murk working with Black Manta.
So Ocean Master really does give Black Manta all of his coolest
toys.  Like you can see him without all of his gear on, holding one of their guns here.
Very alien looking, very aquiline.
It'll be cool to see a lot of the underwater architecture, too.
This seems like the underwater cave where he goes to get that trident.
Like you know when he walks out of the waterfall and bangs
it down and he's wearing his comic book armor
This seems like whatever that set is going to be.
It's probably some underwater cave in some secret location
that has something to do with the Trench.
There's an awesome shot of Mera wearing her crown.
I dunno, people are kinda back and forth on
Amber Heard, but I feel like she definitely looks the part.
you see a bunch of newspaper clippings,
showing that even though he doesn't want anything to do with
the world, he is trying to help people up and down the coast
all throughout his life.  So when we get to Batman v Superman
you see that little clip of him, that's him being
a superhero without him really thinking of himself as a superhero.
Like he's trying to do a good thing, but he hasn't really found his way yet.
So Justice League was sorta the beginning of that, like he found
the team, found a family, and now he's ready to deal with all of this.
There's a bunch of external shots of Amnesty Bay.  It looks
beautiful, but the iconic lighthouse is a really big
comic book location, so it'll be fun to see that.
More of Mera on the beach
wearing her crown, looking like she's either ready to
receive something, or prepared for something really bad to go down,
or really pissed off about something.  She has a resting
face that makes it look like she's getting ready to punch someone at any moment.
Couple of really good underwater shots of her in her costume
getting ready to go meet with Vulko and Aquaman.
This is a good example of how they shoot their underwater scenes.
So notice that this is all dry here.
But when we watch it during the movie, it'll have like that blue tinge to it
and it'll be underwater.
But I really like the way that they color her hair special,
because obviously this is meant to look like it's underwater,
so light will bounce of her a little bit differently.
Her red hair, the green costume...will just pop a little bit
better on screen than they would above water.
All these scenes of them on this boat here with this crazy rain storm
seems like it's from this scene in the trailer when they're getting ready
to dive into the Trench.  You see him grabbing the flare, he
throws it down here.  It looks like there's this giant maelstrom and all these
people of Trench coming up.
So this might be sometime later in the movie, because it
looks like a pretty big action setpiece.  This is the skeleton
of one of the Trench dwellers.  We've gotten a couple of shots of them
trailer so far, but not a really solid look yet.
This is another one of the members of what they call the.
Fisherman race.  Historical context: when Atlantis
sank and the 7 different kingdoms split apart,
theirs just evolved to become more aquatic-like.
So they're more powerful underwater than normal Atlanteans
but they're completely unable to go above water.
But the Atlanteans and the people from Zeble are about half and half; a little more humanoid.  They can survive
just fine above water, but they do a
little bit better underwater.  This is actually a really good
shot here.  They have a camera inside the mouth of a whale
looking like either Aquaman or someone else is gonna swim
in it.  Or there's gonna be an underwater shot of it eating
something and they're gonna give you this crazy perspective of it.
Really good interview with the actor that plays Black Manta.  There is a rumor
right now that there's a mid-credits sequence in the movie that will be mostly Black Manta
oriented, setting up sequel stuff.  Because the actor
did say that he would appear in future DC movies
but he didn't say which ones or what his story would be.  So
obviously he's probably not gonna be a super huge character
during this film.  They'll just introduce him and get him up to his
comic book level.  Then maybe he winds up being the big
bad of the second film, or a much bigger villain than he is in this film.
This Ocean Master interview that Patrick Wilson is doing
seems like it's inside some Atlantean structure.
This is kind of what the inside of their buildings look like.  We got a little
shot of their throneroom in one of the previous trailers, but
you haven't seen a whole lot of the inside of their structures.
Just the outside, because you get that shot like you got in Black Panther
when they first fly into Wakanda.  They do the same thing when they drive
the ship into Atlantis for the first time.  You get that big
wide vista.  Like, look how crazy this is.  There's a cool shot of
Mera in the bar here looking like she's using her powers to grab
all the water from the bottles of
liquor.  So maybe she's trying to get Aquaman's attention
and it seems like when she's first come to try and get him to help out.
Bu overall, looks pretty solid.  Everybody, let me know what you're
most excited about.  I've already done that non spoilery
breakdown of all the early reviews that have posted so far.
but what's gonna happen next is there was a really cool Captain Marvel prequel story
they published within the Infinity War Avenger's 4
storyline.  So I'll do a breakdown of that tomorrow.  And we
found out about another alternate version of the Captain
Marvel Infinity War post-credits scene.  So I'll do a
breakdown of all that stuff, no worries.
Congratulations Jaun Cena, you're the giveaway winner from my last big DC video
Please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your contact details.
click here for that brand new Flash crossover trailer
And click here for my Stan Lee tribute.  Thank you so much for watching.
Everybody stay awesome.  I'll see you guys tonight.